Probably a year ago, this became really popular, right?
This little bottle flip thing, where you just flip a bottle and it happens to
supposed to drop if you do it just right like that.
And what's fascinating is that it seems like this is a huge
thing of luck. I can just sit here and do this all day long, right?
It's just this massive thing of luck that I just happen to be getting lucky when I
actually get the bottle to flip correctly.
But the reality is that's not necessarily luck
apparently it's not skill on the part of myself either however
after a little bit of research you find that this is actually more of a
fine tuning thing there's actually science behind the bottle flip
that it has something to do with the size of the water bottle, this one being
much too small, the amount of water that's in the bottle and how much spin you
actually put on it. And if you get it right every single time and you have just the
right amount of spin and you have just the right amount of water and just the right
bottle, you can never miss. And based on science, it'll always land the way
it's supposed to.
See, we learned from Genesis that this world was created by God.
We know that, right? And we know that God designed it for us.
But what if we really didn't have Scripture to tell us that?
I mean, this tells me that God designed the world.
This tells me that God did it all.
And all I have to do is look at this and go, yeah, okay, I know that.
But what if I didn't have it?
What does this tell me about God's design?
What it tells me is the same thing that nature tells us that all of this fine
-tuning all of these things that we have just right just calculated
just so so that we could actually survive here so that we could
thrive so we could live and breathe and do all the things that we do and we could
have this earth spinning in this universe around the sun and all the way ways that
most of us kind of just accept and take for granted and don't worry too much about
is this really about random chance did
this world just sort of pop into existence and things just happen to
fall in the right way that if I flip this bottle enough times that this universe
just kept starting and restarting and restarting and restarting until one day,
it actually worked. And see, this is deep there.
Now the universe worked. Is that what this, or is this a well-crafted design by God?
That's what this unit is about. But that's what this lesson is about.
This lesson is about looking at our universe and seeing that this is
more than just a random whole bunch of stuff that happened to fall into place at the
right place at the right time. But instead, an actual design and science behind
crafting the right conditions for life to happen.
So for this week, I want you to think about one word.
I want you to think about thinking.
Last week, we kind of introduced the idea that science actually furthers our faith
and lays a crucial foundation for what we believe.
It's great. Well, this is where we start to see that happen.
it. This is where we start to actually have to start thinking about some of these
things and start putting some pieces together.
Think about more than just the thinking cognitive piece of this and the
stuff that you can know, but take a second and think through this for a second.
What does it mean that God has made a place for us?
If you stop and consider this for just one minute.
All these things, whether the atmosphere, the earth's rotation, the distance from
the sun, whatever it is, these things are just so, so that we
can live here. We can thrive here.
That if God designed this, it doesn't just prove or show evidence that God exists.
It doesn't just prove that God gave us a place where it's habitable for us to
actually just survive here but it's made in such a way that God has
created a home for us and he did it with uh with his heart
and with love in mind I mean what does this say about who God is what does
fine-tuning say about the character of God